all right welcome back to the right 10
Club my friends this is your weekly joke
writing challenge where you get a new
word and write a new joke in 10 minutes
today's word of the day you see
scrolling across the screen it is Shake
so we're gonna shake things up a bit
by using our uniball 207 plus I had a
corporate gig this weekend and treated
myself to some new pins and uh uniball
is uh always a good smooth right
so the word of the day is Shake
and I like to use different color ink
too just to shake it up a bit
all right
so we have 10 minutes on the clock where
the day is Shake
feel free to ride along with me feel
free to if you're watching on our
Wednesday live stream when we do this
feel free to uh spit out ideas as I'm
spitting them out and um
let's get into it my friends so 10
minutes where did the day Shake
so to shake things out
first thing I like to do is just get the
ideas out there shake things out not
doing anything right or wrong or good or
bad or funny or not it's just getting
the juices flowing by just what do you
think of when you hear the word shake
what comes to mind
off the jump shake and bake
which is um Talladega Nights
which from that movie Talladega Nights
and look there's no
wrong way to do this this is literally
for the next few minutes just getting as
much out of our head as possible and
then we can start to go back
and formulae it into a joke
um
Shake Your Booty I believe that is a
song right
shake shake shake shake shake shake your
booty
um
uh
pepper shaker you know just getting the
ideas out here pepper shaker
uh James Bond shaken not
stirred
and that's James Bond
there's a common phrase
um
was it don't
Shake
a baby
Shake could be connected to
um
Parkinson's
I think Shake It Off is a song right
is that a t Swift song
uh Shake oh of course
milkshake
milkshake and that makes me think of
like
um lactose intolerance
and there could be some fun uh
word play around
um
shaking off the sugar giving you the
sugar shakes perhaps
um Steak and Shake is one
so see this is why we do the
brainstorming part at the beginning
because it kind of just
it's low pressure you're not trying to
do anything but just word vomiting it
makes the joke riding process very
accessible because you can see in just a
little bit we've already done we've gone
from like movie quotes to uh like food
and to like dancing so and common
phrases and stuff so whatever comes to
mind you know
words phrases
uh tangential connections Shake makes
you think of bake which makes you think
of cooking oh
um
oh nice yeah yeah Augie said Shake
Weights yes indeedy my friends
um
excuse me one second we seem to have
some spam in the live chat
so shake weight is funny though and it
could be
Shake Weight
um
could be no I want to lose weight
so it could be something with um
shake weight because or they should call
it shake fat because that's all you do
as you're shaking it you know
uh Shake It Off Shake It Out
shake and bake shake so I just like to
brainstorm the first half
um just to kind of get the juices
flowing and then the second half we like
to kind of start to organize it into
a nice toit joke
all right so next let's let's get into
it here so milkshake
um I don't know there's something about
milkshake that I like so let me try to
play around with that because I think
there's maybe like a lactose
intolerance joke
uh
uh here so now we want to start
formulating into a joke so
way to do that is you first start off
with your premise so what do you want to
say in this joke so I would like to say
that I love
milkshakes
in the setup but so then in a one-liner
it's a misdirect you're setting up the
auto stick in One Direction and then the
punch line says a second Direction
oh earthquakes is a good one it's Akuma
so I want the punchline to actually say
I hate milkshakes
so you see we're working on creating
that misdirect so your setup should say
one thing but the punchline says the
opposite so for I love milkshakes
what are all the ways we could say I
love milkshakes
my favorite food
is milkshakes
is milk our milkshakes
um
milkshakes are my
favorite
cheat meal
I could
live on
milkshakes
maybe I just
started
a milkshake
diet
and maybe there's something with like uh
juice cleanse
and maybe there's a joke I mean it's
kind of dirty I mean it's a poop it's a
poop joke it's a poop joke
something about
diarrhea
um
milkshake one of the basic food groups
yeah yeah
I'll see you there Tim
food pyramid yeah so maybe there is a
Mystic we can do around
um
yeah it being healthy but in all type
deal you know so I just started a
milkshake diet a juice cleanse
maybe there's a word that rhymes with
juice
or cleanse colon cleanse
I just started a milkshake diet
so just to get the juices flowing my
doctor
recommended
a colon cleanse
milkshake brings all the boys to the
yard
and makes them sit on the toilet brings
all the boys to the yard but if you're
over 30
that yard is an outhouse
a doctor recommended a colon cleanse
milkshake so we're getting we're getting
somewhere here we got about
90 seconds left see if we can get
something here at the buzzer I'd have to
recommend it a colon cleanse milkshake
um
prescribed
what is it called
uh laxative
um
so maybe a milkshake is cheaper than a
laxative
or as I call it a laxative
I just started a new milkshake diet
laxative
milkshakes
30 seconds milk Dairy Queen has the best
I feel like I did a similar joke to this
with a different word but maybe
something around like
Dairy Queen
has the best milkshakes serves Royal
milkshakes
I know why the best milkshakes are at
Dairy Queen all right
so at the buzzer here
Dairy Queen serves Royal milkshakes
right after I'm on the throne
so it's basically trying to say that
they're delicious but they leave me on
the toilet you know
I feel like there was maybe a joke
let's get a word of the day a few weeks
ago where I had a royal Throne joke so I
don't know what that says about me but
writing a joke in in 10 minutes live on
the internet at 10 A.M
you're welcome for even doing this for
free so
to kind of land the plane here
um
all right
I now
how
Dairy Queen got
its name
their milk shakes
to me on the throne
on the porcelain throne
so
not great
not something I'm gonna do on stage
anytime soon but
the whole name of this game is to sit
down and write for 10 minutes to focus
on just nothing but silly Joe crying for
10 minutes
and if you've watched this before you
know the name of the game is repetition
so you write 20 jokes and end up keeping
one so
hopefully this at least got your juices
flowing and you can use this as a
jumping off point to spark some riding
momentum that you can then take into
your day
after this keep writing you know this is
just a little brainstorming exercise
that I hope helped you out there and if
it did subscribe and tell your fellow
comedy writers to um hang out with us
here at the hopper at the verse on our
podcast we release every Monday on our
Tuesday live streams or our Wednesday
live streams it's all about Comics
helping Comics here
so we'll see you next week y'all
bye